we're back for another day of e3 today i
am heading to the microsoft showcase
where i'm going to be playing a couple
of games
i believe we'll be playing forza
hopefully some minecraft
fingers crossed for sea of thieves
because i've been hyped on that game
since last year when they announced it
at e3
and guess who i have spotted it's my
incredible escort
it's me jenna e escort or a babysitter
just kidding
yeah i'm back
[Music]
we need to chat we were just on steve
harvey today yeah we were
yeah we were it was incredible it was it
was cool i had so much fun
i'm so much larger than you like you
have to like lift your arm up to vlog
you guys can i just do that look what i
do i do the sideways turn we got us both
[Music]
we made it in let's see what we can oh
i'm super pumped about forza let's play
let's play
connor has a car in here do you know
that yes okay
hi how are you
it's been a couple years okay you can
choose from three drivers
and this is the new car we announced on
stage so good
right 911 gt2 rs
and then we've got a truck actually a
race truck and then we've got this
nissan
this one this one has our brand new
track which is dubai it's a fictional
track i should probably play that one
then yeah yeah
all right guys we're about to start
playing some forza this is recording in
4k
at 60 frames a second i got to show you
guys the really cool capture stations
that they have
they're called this ninja inferno you
basically slide in a solid state drive
and you can report directly to the drive
it's pretty
so sorry i'm so sorry you're in my way
you're gonna have to get out of my way
you will not pass bill
[Music]
i just think about the damage
i've hit a lot of things jen
[Music]
all right we're rolling up one now 11th
place
yeah we're getting there
started from the bottom like literally
started from the bottom
i'm taking this straight away and i'm
making this mine
i'm getting very upset with these people
in front of me so mad i gotta i got it
okay we're going back into the dark now
[Music]
come on one place fourth place fourth
one come on come on come on come on oh
my gosh sweet yes yes yes
okay okay we're making progress what's
it gonna be what's it gonna be
hey top three first time playing
i'm pretty proud i mean the game looks
really good
my favorite part about this is always
going back and seeing the destruction
that i've done to my car
so this is something that i think you
guys need to check out this is the
inside of the new xbox one
x here's the internals let's check it
out
[Music]
we're mostly sea of thieves i played it
last year at e3 so now we've got some
more things that are playable
we're basically playing the part that
they showed in the xbox press conference
should i stab you i'm so sorry no
friendly fire
oh well i'm in the water so
i missed the press x to climb memo
[Music]
nice view
i'm helping out back here now
i just want to jump off the ship really
bad
probably
okay you ready all right well there you
go
okay all right hop in
okay ready uh all right
there you go have fun
[Music]
i can't go any further maybe we should
yeah it won't let me
turn any further away so you're gonna
have to hit the rod
so the hardest thing about me trying to
gameplay for you guys right now is the
fact that you can't actually hear my
teammates talking to me so essentially
it looks like i'm talking to myself but
i'm not
i'm talking to my teammates it's also
kind of hard because at the event there
was a lot of loud music playing
so you can't really hear me very well
but you hear the music but i want you to
hear the gameplay but i want you to hear
me talking so it's kind of difficult
so i'm just going to cut up this video
pretty quickly for you so we can go
through some of the gameplay from sea of
thieves our main task was we were trying
to find a graveyard
to dig up some treasure my teammates got
confused i was confused somebody had to
go back to the ship so that they could
look at the map to find out what it was
and then we got confused and we
completely mixed up the riddle we
thought we were supposed to go west but
it was actually
south east a lot of things happen i so
wish you guys could have heard the
dialogue that was happening between my
teammates because it was really really
funny i'm super excited for this game i
feel like it's one of those games that
doesn't take itself too seriously
it's gonna be super fun to play with
your friends and i look forward to
playing with mine
and maybe you guys if i happen to open
up a lobby on xbox live
all right guys that was
oh man it was actually really fun not a
very good pirate
my navigational skills non-existent so
we just sat on a place of minecraft and
i picked up the xbox controller
it is minecraft theme i mean granted a
brown controller you wouldn't think
would look good
i mean this is so minecraft theme it
hurts so now we're gonna be playing on
one of these networks i kind of stopped
playing for a while but man for about
like two years i was super into
minecraft i had a server
you guys loved the server and what i'm
wondering from you
is should i bring back ij minecraft
if you think i should leave a comment
below now let's hop into this
let me hit record on my capture station
oh man we are
now in the server so this is so
different because i usually don't play
on console i mostly play
on pc but one of the best things is you
can now play on basically anything you
can play on your phone
you can play on xbox you can play on
windows you can play basically anywhere
and you can all
be here and ready to party with your
friends also unfortunate you guys can't
hear the conversations that i was having
with my fellow minecraft friends as well
and i'm saying this now please do not
judge me for playing
so terribly at the beginning of this
video having played minecraft for
several years on a pc and then to go
straight to console and having zero
concept of the controls
yeah go ahead give me crap for it you go
try it and then
please don't hurt me i am not prepared
for this i don't even
please leave me alone oh god i can't
i am not prepared
i need a pc
yeah i'm absolute trash
i'm like hitting people with me i only
have
jesus so guys that's it here for the
xbox showcase hope you guys enjoyed this
let me know what games you guys are most
looking forward to
there have been so many games announced
that i'm getting like
super anxious like how am i gonna have
time to play all of these
i don't know let's go we got some other
things to do today
thanks jen
[Music]
so we're about to head on to the youtube
e3 live stream i'm super excited i did
this last year and we're back again
they're in a new location this time
check out the set
to our youtube creators lounge to hear
thoughts on e3
from the perspective of some of
youtube's top creators and joining us
right now are
nadeshot and ijustine along with
alexander gross and ellen
rose guys uh take it away we can't wait
to hear what you think of e3
what is your favorite thing you've seen
so far there's been so much
yeah like it's actually been kind of
overwhelming i was actually pretty
impressed with the ubisoft
press conference yeah me too it was way
better than i thought because usually
like they have like especially their the
the just dance numbers are yeah
you know not the best and i thought bb
rex actually was pretty incredible oh
that's pretty cool
um i give that conference an a for all
right
because first of all where's tonic
trouble come on guys i want a sequel to
tonic trouble for the n64 let's see it
happen
that you know that's just my opinion i'm
a huge far cry fan
[Music]
okay far cry primal wasn't the biggest
fan far cry 4 because basically
primal i feel like was just like a
reskin of four
man five i'm i'm excited me and my huge
far cry fan i'm here for one reason and
one reason only oh boy here we go
sony conference we're getting the call
of duty world war ii reveal
they've gotten rid of created class
that's rumored that they might be
bringing vehicles back
to world war ii and i heard you're
really into the vehicles oh yeah i love
the vehicles i think it's great for
multi-players
yeah they should definitely add them in
it's okay it's just it's the cornerstone
of consistency in first-person shooters
so
i'm just waiting for the sony press
conference i was very excited about
scorpio
uh but still call of duty is my game and
i gotta be here for that specifically
what's it called the xbox one x
yeah yeah xbox one x yeah scorpio i
can't wait for xbox one xx
accent core plus r yeah
yeah i just got back from the microsoft
showcase i played some sea of thieves
it was actually fun it's really good
it's like it doesn't take itself too
seriously
like it's super fun and it was just
great to sort of like play with a bunch
of people that i didn't even know yeah
having a really good time did you say
sea of thieves yes oh my god i played it
last year
yeah e3 when it was in like chloe free
alpha
pre-alpha yeah yeah i can't wait because
that was the one game it won a bunch of
rewards yeah i was super intrigued by
now it was pretty fun
is it just me or are there a lot of
pirate games coming out like a lot of
pirates yeah
skull and bones skull and bones thieves
everyone's catching up to one piece yeah
it's true
yeah they only got five thousand
episodes to go
i've never really played much of the
assassin's creed stuff oh yeah
but the new one kind of looks
interesting i mean it seems like it's
something completely different than what
they've been doing in the past yeah
because they usually go forward in time
yeah now they're going
way back yeah so it's like they've
updated the series as well it seems as
well they've taken
a lot of things from far cry so you've
got the roaming and everything like that
and you've got your you know eagle pal
flying over and marking things from far
cry primal um
and then you've got all these rpg
elements as well so it feels like
you know assassin's creed and witcher 3
like had a baby and that's quite
exciting for me
so have we talked about call of duty yet
no
but i feel like somebody in this group
wants to this disclaimer really quickly
okay i do want to say because my
comments sound a little too negative i'm
very
optimistic about what sledgehammer is
going to do with world war ii and i'm
very very excited for the trailer
this is like mostly excited about that
at a long time that's a good that's a
good option
let me just say right well it did it did
come off it but i i have uh
a lot of faith in that that studio right
there and i think they're gonna knock it
out
on the part i think most people know
that i'm like a really huge call of duty
fan and i didn't really play much of the
last one
i played way more remastered than i
actually did play with the real game so
i don't know i'm excited i don't think
anybody played infinite warfare but
wow that is laying it down here guys
that brings today to a close there's so
much more to come this week i can't wait
i hope you guys enjoyed some of the
gameplay from today i'm so looking
forward to the nintendo press conference
i cannot wait to see what they announced
and i'm hoping that mario odyssey will
be playable on the show floor let me
know what you guys are most looking
forward to
there was so much that happened today we
have the sony press conference the
ubisoft press conference
and there's only more to come i can't
even believe it like the actual show
hasn't even started yet we'll see you
guys later
you